Aleksandra it's lovely to see you here
today at collector mania how you've been
enjoying it it's been great it's been
really lovely to see people's reactions
to the show and yeah meet so many people
it's been a buzz now of course we know
your honor here on a flying visit aren't
you could you're heading back out to the
Musketeers sir
yeah I'm going back out tomorrow morning
yeah flying it's interpreter this time
not Prague was filming in Moravia which
should be nice different location so
yeah so in the middle of filming
Musketeers season 3 and it's going well
so it's fun shame not to be here with
Brian he's coming some more over there
we go what can fans expect from the
season 3 the same what they love but
also some new villains and great new
storylines but I don't want to give
anything away of course you also in part
of another massive show Game of Thrones
what was it like being part of that that
was brilliant
yeah again feel massively privileged to
have even been there and stepped onto
the set and to been a part of it and to
be remembered for a tiny little yeah to
be part of like a really great episode
as well was just such a joy it is I mean
it is a fantastic show and yeah it felt
very lucky what are the chances you
think we'll see you back again on Game
of Thrones because of course you married
and we were didn't you yeah I did and I
haven't died yet so I always keep my
fingers crossed but I haven't had the
call yet nothing yeah I'm writing in
what would you like to see happen for
her in the future if you did get back
onto the show
I don't know it's all about the game
Game of Thrones isn't it everyone wants
to get get to the throne maybe we'll get
together eventually it's not very nice
family or from know is it the phrase no
maybe we could see her
well I quite like playing a bit of a
nasty side so maybe we could see how
come out with the Walder Frey yeah well
her dad's sort of tendencies might come
out that would be good that could be fun
how shocked do you think Robb Stark was
when he saw you walk out and realize
that you were the woman he could have
married who's to say I mean we like to
think that he was very upset but I don't
know was it like filming that things of
course it was such a major part of that
season three wasn't it the red wedding
yeah it was it was amazing to be part of
that scene so there's so many people in
that scene that I mean it's watched the
show and everything so I knew who they
all weren't to be part of all the
different families coming together but
you know the Starks and the phrase and
to be there and seeing all of that was
was great I I mean I actually wasn't
there for the part where everyone got
massacred so it was almost as much of a
shock to me when I watched it as other
people I think I didn't realize quite
how how much that would be even though I
know it's going to happen
you